[موسيقى]
أنت
هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، أود أن أثني على
القادة الإماراتيين لإزالة الحواجز التي تحول دون
انضمام النساء إلى القوى العاملة
ووضع إستراتيجية وطنية
تعترف بأن المرأة عنصر أساسي
للنمو المستدام في العام الماضي ، أكثر من
70 في المائة من خريجي الجامعات الإماراتيين
النساء 70 في المائة ، إنه أمر
لا يصدق ،
لكن 10 في المائة فقط من إجمالي الدخل القومي لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
مشتق من النساء
، ونحن نعلم أن هذا سوف ينمو
ويزدهر في السنوات المقبلة.
في
منطقة شمال إفريقيا لإدخال
إصلاحات مهمة على مدار العامين
الماضيين ، غيرت المملكة العربية السعودية قوانينها
لاحترام حرية المرأة في التنقل
والوصول إلى الخدمات الائتمانية والمالية.
أدخلت البحرين تشريعات
لمنع التمييز في مكان العمل
[تصفيق]
ألغى الأردن القيود القانونية على
المرأة  القدرة على العمل ليلا
وسع المغرب حقوق المرأة في الأرض وتو
أدخلت جمعية nisia قوانين مهمة لمكافحة
العنف الأسري ، نحتاج جميعًا إلى الإشادة
بهذه الإنجازات والتطورات
، ومع ذلك فإننا لن نشعر بالرضا عن الذات لأنه
لا يزال هناك الكثير من العمل الذي يتعين
القيام به ، ولا تزال العديد من النساء يواجهن
عقبات أمام دخول سوق العمل
لبدء أعمالهن الخاصة  الوصول إلى
إمكاناتهم الكاملة ورسم مستقبلهم